cette série on va accueillir celui ci
d'adorer celui pour réclamer tous les
soirs c'est andreas qui est avec nous
applaudissements pour mieux vous l'avez
remarqué un jour une peau un un truc
d'où ce mec là nous avons chez les
messieurs nous harnais alors il
s'intéressait aux télés locales
aujourd'hui le groupe s'est arrêté à
aller dans la rue poser une question aux
français sur ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end situé à bray la rubrique
maintenant il ya il a mis un non plus
alors on s'appelle les français sont
sympas les français sont sympa alors
aujourd'hui il était en tout cas la
campagne pour l'instant toujours on y va
alors je suis venu avec une émission qui
s'appelle jacques il est plus propre ça
passe tous les jours sur idf1 c'est pas
une dinde ans et le reste on prend ça
avec jacky jackie chan jacky corbier je
comprends alors dans cette émission n'a
pas de public mais heureusement on a
donné une jolie boîte à son âge acquis
pour faire croire qu'ils avaient du
public problème c'est que je crois que
ça agit pas sur le les invités de
manière super stylé à au niveau de
l'ambiance donc j'ai le pp c'est
l'émission inculte
figure à peu près une heure donc c'était
tumeur 1h15 1h03 d'accord tu l'as fait
je vais rencontrer jacques et jared me
suis senti un ouais c'est un amour il ya
que ces légendes mais t'avais il arrive
à mettre l'ambiance avec rien mais ça
délire juste avec un mouton c'est fou
c'est sa marque en grec c'est une bande
j'ai une bombe au bâton l'adorent et au
début de chacune de ses émissions
l'invité lâche une petite vanne pour
détendre l'atmosphère dommage la
l'invité à la chine vannes petit lâche
compte et posé avec tes potes au balto
pas compter à la télé à 17h30
heureusement jacques qui a su désamorcer
dirais que c'est l'histoire de deux
villes qui vont au cinéma hellène qui
dit à l'autre
donc j'espère que ce soit ce n'est pas
encore une docu s'en sort encore passé
la soirée de vous raconter meeting le 6
juin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les quatre ans tu as tu me la remet à la
fin les origines
on vous le dit dix minutes avant cas
comme ça c'est mieux
d'accord ok bon et comme vous le savez
dans le paf ya deux types d' animateur
d'un côté il ya drucker qui sait
accueillir ses invités qui les met à
l'aise de l'autre côté aja qui lui dit
complètement ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils
étaient à défoncer l'invité à petit a
ainsi trouvé ma chance et carros je
voulais même trousse de carrosserie de
citron et non pas sur ce spectacle
bêtement un trépied ressort c'est de
dire bahia rachedi jean richard iii
jacent internet rouge dans la charpente
un peu ça brasse j'ai fait ça pour les
mettre à l'aise a pas si l'accueil est
super bien marché ils sont en train de
regagner les recalés bon alors comme
vous l'avez vu dans cette émission ils
ont pas mis le budget sur la déco c'est
plein de bonnes raisons c'est parce
qu'ils ont mis le budget sur les cadeaux
dont je déconne vous avez gagné la photo
dédicacée de la sublimissime de la
divine les labex ti sauf que c'est moi
qui vais y dédicacer la photo c'est bien
ça
[Applaudissements]
mais là j'ai pas l'accès tout parce
qu'on est là c'est parce que c'est un
génie de kai s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on à
cancale c'est paul lucas c'est d'abord
tu peux pas d'attentes ont l'âge de le
faire moi je préfère un kif dans les
livres d'or lui mais c'est vrai je l
adore ce n'est qu il aurait pu signer un
post it le gars bon ce week-end c'était
aussi le match om paris
bien sûr je vous les regardez pas sur
canal j'ai regardé sur par pm viennent
c'est la chaîne locale marseillaise
alors c'est des animateurs qui commente
le match pour vous qui le regardent pour
vous du coup quand ils regardent ils
peuvent s'énerver comme vous
malheureusement ils savent se censurer
problème ils se sont sûrs après avoir
insulté du coup ça sentait n'ya même pas
faute c'est lui qui se jettent dessus
allez vas-y marquinhos une chèvre cm2 tu
as l'air l'homme ya 25 ans de tamerlan
[Applaudissements]
mais en même temps il n'y avait pas
faute sur martinez là normalement là
s'il avait jacky loi talent et didier
marotte et avait pas photo dézingue
match nul
on sent pas dans les tribunes avec les
winners on n'était pas content énervé il
ya les deux vous faire une très belle
saison
voilà que j'ai on embrasse soit là tous
les clubs de france des clubs riches
cheikhs et ben du coup je suis désolé
pour l'algérie nommé comme vous le savez
paris a gagné 2 0 du coup quand et
commentateurs que tu es marseillais et
que tu annonces le deuxième but de paris
niveau ambiance en plateau c'est pas
france-brésil 98 et attention mais mark
a fait un joli appelle là alors je et
taxes l'art qui marque 2 0
paris la sortie du match est fini
termine ici ou fairway bon après ça chez
les dans la rue bien sûr comme vous le
savez ce week-end on est passée à
l'heure d'hiver du coup je suis allé
demander aux français s'ils y avait
débat ou pas au sujet de cette question
alors moi je suis un journaliste très
consciencieuse j'essaie toujours de
faire en sorte de régler tous les petits
détails avant des séquences pour qu'elle
soit nickel
bon du coup je suis peut-être un peu
trop consciencieux remy je suis
peut-être un peu relou heureusement que
les français seront sympas en gros je
t'explique moi je fais un petit sujet là
pour une école de journalisme
donc il faut que mon sujet soit nickel
ça soit bien fait j'ai deux trois petits
réglages à faire et au niveau d'accord
on fait peut-être ça n'a pas bâti ce
qu'est ce que tu penses du passage à
l'heure d'hiver cible micro que je pense
qu'à l'heure actuelle on appliquait aux
changements depuis ça dérange pas que
dans les rideurs des plus soudées moi
non je pense qu'on est habitué après
tout
on y va il faut parler fort on a le
problème est que les micros depuis ce
matin là maintenant la bonne réponse
en parlant fort ok ce week-end on est
passée à l'heure d'hiver et ça nous a
permis de dormir une heure de plus cela
bien d'autres choses dont on doit se
préoccuper je suis à la retraite au
niveau de lumière on n'est pas au fait
ça va ok alors c'est une bonne nouvelle
ou pas que le soleil se couche plus tôt
cette nuit quoi plus lui non plus lui
ben les gens nous crabe est assez
rapidement si on fait quoi on voit pas
maman là dans le cadre on préfère un
truc en large ok je lève le 30 au 2 mai
quoi photo à c'est une bonne idée ou une
mauvaise idée
ouais bon jean rien compris j'aimerais
qu'on remettre extrait de chaque qui
vous a rappelé voilà alors il ya des
mecs voilà en plateau il ya un mec sur
une blague et jacky ne se démonte jamais
même si la blague et il reste
l'animateur pour enfants il s'est
toujours rattraper la situation
jacky ickx club de rotterdam si
l'histoire de david qui vont cinéma
hellène qui dit à l'autre pour qui donc
l'espère ce soir ce n'est pas encore une
docu s'en sort encore passé la soirée de
vous
[Applaudissements]
chroniqueur et il est excellent comme
beaucoup il est par contre chez tf1
[Rires]